the dream of a flying car that was a
promise that was an unfulfilled promise
from childhood that we would all be in
flying cars by now and I'm convinced
this is as close to that object to a
flying car in my lifetime this is maria
del camino' and so she's kind of chimera
frankenstein between 59 El Camino and
this Komatsu excavator for the base and
then things are completely re configured
and there's a custom boom assembly that
connects the two together and certainly
the 59 El Camino which is you know
famous for the fins and Harley Earl the
designer at GM who was responsible for
the Cadillacs of the era and the
lengthening lowering and widening of
cars tail fins and all that this was the
last car he did for GM and if there was
ever a car that wanted to fly it was the
59 El Camino
so it was a five ton machine originally
and actually Maria in it her complete
form is still now five tons once again
so she's a big girl
the the holes are all hand drilled and
they form a halftone image of the false
Maria from Phil metropolis and and the
the basic premise that started that
whole idea was that the car as I found
it was a complete rust bucket and it was
too far shot to be restored into a car
of any value so the idea was to take it
the other direction and turn turn her
into a ghost of herself it's a beast and
so I wanted to perforate the body and so
then the question came up well if I'm
going to perforate the body then what
pattern would I use
I had always been inspired by the film
metropolis and the robot woman or
actually as Fritz Lang called it the
robot machine man but I call her the
false Maria hence the name in the Adele
Camino
really you know the best thing about it
and one of the reasons I created it was
to ride with friends a group of friends
in the car and being up off the earth
there's something quite sublime in that
sense
you